you know that's a that's a good question
i'm not sure how much of an impact my
work really has on the world I mean I
credible I you know created blogs that
are read by a lot of people you know
engadget alone like I said gets about 9
million readers a month you know if we
count joystick gizmodo a handful of
others I mean it's you know it's
definitely in you know above 10 million
and probably you know getting closer to
20 million which is great it's not
something that like feels real to me in
any way because I still work from home
and I still just sit in my apartment and
you know answer email and stuff like
that it's not like a it doesn't feel
real at all in the way that like if I
was doing it in a stadium or something
like that you know I like getting in a
concert in front of people it's a
thought like when you're a musician and
you go from playing like a bar to like
you know Madison Square Garden you can
sort of really feel the transition it
feels the same I mean doing gadget for
nine million people feels the same as
doing it you know for 90,000 was so you
know in that respect like I don't
necessarily it's I don't necessarily
feel or have a good sense of necessarily
of the impact I mean I think that I was
someone that was able to figure out a
lot of stuff in blogging first and I
think you know I definitely hope I made
a positive contribution to the world of
blogging and and you know hope maybe on
some level inspired people with gizmodo
and engadget to start their own blogs
which i think is great i mean i think i
think it's a good thing for people to be
starting blogs and a good thing for
people to be expressing themselves even
if you're just expressing yourself to
like you know 10 of your friends I think
that's our that alone is like a great
thing but I don't know beyond that I
mean you know occasionally we'll see you
know people in industry will talk to me
and tell me about you know that the
people that work at the company the
manufacturer or whatever they read
engadget and pay attention and you sort
of want to be able to feel like well
maybe they do listen and you know
because we consider ourselves and it got
to be kind of advocates for you know the
consumer people who are really you know
to be kind of the that there's no
difference like the reason why I in
gadget works i think is because we're
writing it for ourselves because we're
the audio
and and we don't have any reason to kind
of like the ourselves you know
and so you kind of hope on some level
that that people do listen but you know
I don't want I don't want to overstate
like the impact by any means I'm not you
know I'm not someone that built a you
know a Microsoft or you know I'm not
like Steve Jobs or anything like that I
mean I think there's a tendency for
people who work in the media to sort of
confuse themselves with the people that
they're covering and I definitely do not
do that I mean I definitely recognize
that at the end of the day it's a gadget
blog it's not you know I'm not saving
lives and I'm not curing cancer and you
know it's it's the most I can hope for
is that people you know who read the
site find some value and going to it and
that maybe I've made a few people laugh
with them you know some of the
irreverent wit that I like to pretend
that I have